hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt samira und ich wir wollen heute was
ganz leckeres machen
weißt du noch was wir machen eine tolle
pizza
ich hatte ja schon nachdem galileo
beitrag dieses land gemacht und da habe
ich die nutella pizza gemacht aber ich
wollte euch jetzt eben auch noch mal als
kurzes video zeigen und einfach nochmal
die genauen schritte weil in dem langen
video war das nicht so ganz deutlich
deswegen sage ich euch jetzt mal ganz
kurz die zutaten für den teig und später
dann eben für den belag
also wir brauchen etwas hotel also
ungefähr ein drittel bis ein halbes glas
und ein glas nähe
das war es auch schon ich mach das jetzt
hier in so einem blender also in so
einem mixer aber ihr könnt auch ganz
normal eine küchenmaschine nehmen oder
zusammen sind der hand verkneten ist es
völlig egal oder ein handrührgerät jetzt
gebe ich ein teil des mädels hier rein
ja das halbe glas tschuldigung ja ganz
kurz hoch dann das okay und ist nutella
wird das machen wir mit dem löffel jetzt
geben wir ungefähr so ein halbes glas
nutella 30 das noch ich kurz damit es
nicht so sehr verschmiert
es gebe ich noch mal ein bisschen mehr
drauf aber ich lass noch ein wenig übrig
und vermixt es ist einfach kurz
und wenn ihr matter teig ist zu flüssig
oder zu feucht geht das mit 1
und am ende sollte er einfach so eine
konsistenz haben so eine weiche aber
bald nicht mehr kleben
dann ist der teig auch schon ganz
schnell hergestellt und dann nehme ich
ihnen nehme ich hier noch direkt raus
ich mach das ganze jetzt hier auf meiner
back folien so stern hotel öffnen kleine
maus
aber ich nehme dir mal lieber das glas
weg nehme ich mir noch ein bisschen mehl
und form das jetzt zu einer kugel also
ihr seht der teig der klebt nicht mehr
so ich kann den schönen formen und dann
hat er eben auch schon die perfekte
konsistenz und der weit hergestellt
innerhalb von halben minute ungefähr
und jetzt wird es ganz schön geformt wie
so eine pizza also wie im richtigen
pizzateig mit pizza bisher nee das geht
nicht
es geht mir normalen tag aber mit dem
ich mit dem durch die eine hand immer so
als rand und mit der anderen könnte dann
so mit den fingern bisschen nach aus
reformen und dann entsteht eben auch so
ein schöner pizza rand
genau ist noch ganz viele löcher rein
stechen dann bleibt der teig nämlich
beim backen schön flach okay du sollst
nicht umbringen sondern muss ein
bisschen watte brüssel so gleichmäßig
dann geht da nicht hoch und bleibt schön
flach und den ziehe ich das auf meine
backblech und praxis jetzt im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 170 grad für
ungefähr 13 minuten danach lass ich's
komplett abkühlen und dann umstellen die
pizza gleich fertig wir schauen sehr
schnell ist mir sehr
jetzt ist der nutella teig fertig und
auch komplett abgekühlt und ich setze
ihn jetzt auch direkt man auf eine
schöne platte geht auch ganz leichte
sicher visum keks und jetzt habe ich
hier noch ein paar zutaten das sind ganz
wenige ihr könnt auch ganz verschiedene
zutaten benutzen
ich mache seine leckere creme noch drauf
damit auch die früchte schönen
traumhaften und das bringt auch so ein
bisschen feuchtigkeit um geschmack mit
rein und die creme besteht bei mir aus
zwei zutaten und zwar wie hier eine
selbstgemachte erdbeer marmelade und
etwas philadelphia frischkäse und dann
belege ich das ganze mit bunten obst
happy wie zb fußball ist hier noch ein
paar mandarinen also alles was ihr
gerade habt alles schön kunterbunt so
und da gibts eigentlich auch keine
genaue mengenangaben am besten da so ein
halbes päckchen oder drei vierteln
halbes päckchen das reicht dann kommt da
marmelade mit dazu nachgeschmack
verrühren spricht besser als es aussieht
die creme streiche ich jetzt drauf
jetzt nehme ich mir das obst die kiwis
scheele ich jetzt zum beispiel um das
andere schönheit hier einfach schönen
form
und jetzt belege ich die pizza einfach
so wie es mir gefällt von außen nach
innen und schaue einfach dass er
komplett mit den früchten bedeckt ist
unsere pizza ist jetzt fertig sieht gut
aus oder aber die schmeckt bestimmt
super und jetzt schneiden wir sie an
vielleicht nicht die schmeckt richtig
lecker und das ist so ein rezept das ist
man jetzt einfach aus der hand
denn wir haben jetzt unter diesem
knusprigen cage teig und da braucht man
keine gabel und kein messer
das ist man einfach so von der hand und
möchte probieren und ich probiere mein
stück jetzt gleich aber nicht jetzt
ich mache es gleich in die kamera dann
aus ist bin ich aber die pizza schon
ziemlich oft gegessen schon sehr oft
nach gemacht auch wenn wir im urlaub
fahren habe ich sie schon macht gemacht
und es ist ein ganz einfaches rezept vor
allem wenn man einfach mal ganz schnell
ein dessert zaubern möchte und nicht
viel zeit hat mich will zutaten hat und
einfach so ein bisserl was mit obst
möchte ich schreibe euch das rezept auf
jeden fall trotzdem aufs eis - blog.de
und freue mich wenn ihr das nachmacht
beim live event mir auch ganz viele
fleißig mitgemacht und mehr fotos
geschickt und ich freue mich wenn ich
freue mich wenn es weiterhin eben auch
macht und wir sehen uns dann ganz
einfach das nächste mal wieder ist dann
tschüss
ab juni
ja
colin clark